sur place au tribunal notre reporter
katia pique nique toujours quatre alors
quelle résonance cet attentat at il dans
le cadre du procès des attaques de
janvier 2015
vous imaginez qu'il ya beaucoup
d'émotions ici déjà le 25 septembre une
première attaque avait eu lieu devant
les anciens locaux de charlie hebdo
savait vraiment glacé les participants à
ce procès et puis est bien juste avant
ce week end c'était une nouvelle plongée
dans la barbarie nouvelle atteinte à la
liberté d'expression et ça s'est
ressenti au tribunal ce matin de chose
rare le président a fait une déclaration
en saluant la mémoire du professeur
décapité et puis de nombreux avocats des
parties civiles se sont exprimées
notamment richard malka l'avocat de
charlie hebdo il a salué la mémoire du
professeur également il à resituer le
contexte de la publication de ces
caricatures il avait été interviewé peu
avant par un sébastien dufour je vous
propose de l'écouter
ils s'en prennent à tous les fondements
de la république et à tout le monde
ils ont tué des juifs ils ont tué des
musulmans ils ont tué des chrétiens ils
tuent tout le monde
ils ce sont les fanatiques islamistes ce
sont les fascistes islamistes
ils n'ont pu prospérer que grâce à cette
arme de destruction massive de notre
république que sont les accusations
d'islamophobie constante que sont la
culpabilisation la victimisation
constante
là c'est cette rhétorique de
l'humiliation en inventant des faits
comme l'a fait ce père de famille qui
appelait à la haine
dans une vidéo et dans la fille n'était
même pas dans le court calé à la
coquette elle était censée avoir assisté
tout ça on le connaît y ait 50 rapport
et on n'a rien fait mais il faut bien
aussi que ce procès avancé aujourd'hui
c'est l'audition d'un nouvel accusés
mais tin carassou l'art alors il est
accusé d'avoir participé à une filière
des angles filières dites bajil tenait
un garage et à mehdi coulibaly s'y est
rendue jusqu'à une semaine avant les
attentats officiellement pour la vente
d'une voiture mais le faible prix de
vente pourrait faire penser à une
compensation en armes et d'ailleurs des
notes concernant des
ont été retrouvés dans les poubelles du
garage l'accusé nie formellement
jusqu'ici il en train de se défendre
dans le box expliquant qu'il n'a rien à
voir avec tout ça peut-être que
l'audition nous permettra de mieux
comprendre ce qu'il s'est passé
merci katia pour toutes ces précisions